[Music]
welcome back to next episode of what's
up prof hello again walter
good day how are you doing i'm just fine
that's good let's open with the word of
prayer
our heavenly father thank you so much
for bringing us again
and having a discussion we ask that you
bless the discussion and we also ask
that you
enlighten our minds with the holy spirit
in jesus name amen
amen
so we can again go through a few
questions
as we have hundreds of them yes
so every now and then we do a question
and answer session
yes okay so i'll ask the question again
and you can answer if i can yes
okay all right first question
the catholics claim that the jesuit oath
is a forgery
from robert ware who was a forger and
that the oath has been debunked
they further claim that the fact that
the oath can be found in library of
congress
also isn't a valid proof for its
authenticity
since even fictitious works can be
published there
so my question basically is is the
jesuit oath a forgery or
or not and what proof do we have for its
authenticity
all right it is recorded in the library
of congress
but that's not the only place where it
appears you will find it in
many historic books you will find it in
protestant writings
and many ex-jesuits have confirmed it
so whether they try to hide it or not
is actually irrelevant the other point
of course is
the proof of the pudding is in the
eating
and if you read what the oath says
then all of those methods
that are listed there have been employed
by the jesuit order and it's associated
over the years they had a reign of
terror
when they ran the inquisition in rome
not in the rest of the place but in rome
which by the way
continued even after the general
inquisition was
gone they were known for their
exceptional cruelty so
whether it is a fake as they claim
or not they seem to adhere to it very
closely very well yeah yes okay
thank you let's go to the next question
is caiaphas going to die three times
considering a resurrection by the second
coming
and then another resurrection after the
millennium if yes
is there any biblical base for this
well the bible is quite clear
in revelation 1 verse 7 where it says
that every eye will see him
including those that pierced him
now those that were involved in the
crucifixion
and we could we could
we could think about this and say well
christ says that he
is pierced also when his followers
are mutilated by his enemies they have
done it unto him
so the idea is that the scripture brings
forth
is that these people will receive a
special resurrection
to see him coming and they will be
destroyed by the brightness
of his coming and then
after the millennium they will be
resurrected again
and then again fire will come down from
the from heaven
and devour them so yes there is a
a biblical reason for saying
that the worst persecutors of christ
maybe even through the ages will be the
ones
that will receive a special resurrection
and you know people being resurrected
and dying and being resurrected again
doesn't only mean that the unrighteous
suffer such
consequences or fortunately get such
consequences for example lazarus yeah he
was dead and he
was raised from the dead and
then he went to sleep again and he will
be raised
so lazarus already has died twice yes
that's not breaking doing any
injustice to the doctrine of the second
resurrection
absolutely not so it is it is a logical
thing that those that
mocked and and scoured him and
and nailed him to the cross and those
that were instrumental
in these acts of torture will receive a
special resurrection
and that is only just and fair yeah yes
thank you okay next question
the sons of god does that mean angels
and if not how do we know it's not
talking about angels
were the giants a product of the fallen
angels and the daughters of men
i understand that the angels cannot
procreate but what if they took the form
of
men the book of enoch also mentions
other fallen angels names
that are not mentioned in the bible and
one last question
why wasn't the book of enoch included in
the bible
very well now when the bible speaks
about the sons of god
it could be a reference to angels
because the sons of god sang together
when this
world was created yes so other created
beings which
could include angels we don't know what
the other created beings look like we
know about angels
but adam is also called son of god yes
so you
humans are also sons of god
so do angels procreate well this person
already understands
that the bible is clear that they don't
so if they don't then procreation for
them
is nothing short of wishful thinking
so who were the sons of god
well the sons of god like adam
were those that were created by god
and were in tune with god's requirements
and in harmony with his will
so over the ages this this term has been
applied to the children of god the
children of israel
the children of god and those that were
the children of men
that were humanists and neglected or
rejected
god so when the sons of god saw that the
daughters of men were beautiful
and then intermarried with them
that means that those who were in the
faith intermarried with those that were
not in the faith and the result you can
see in the world today
correct so we should not says the
bible be unequally yoked
it is not a wise decision and
it is it is a tumultuous
relationship when people are
unequally yoked so the sons of god
were the offspring from the line of adam
that remained faithful and the children
of men were the offspring
of cain and those that did not
remain faithful and he meant eventually
they intermingled
especially of course because the
daughters of cain
made sure that they looked especially
delightful and therefore
these things started to happen now the
word giants
is nephilim and
it is sometimes translated giants yes
and sometimes it is translated to
refer to apostates so
there's no doubt that the people were
gigantic yes
adam was in excess of three meters
and every animal was larger we can see
that in the fossil record if you go to
the fossil record you'll see that
everything was bigger
in the past than it was today i mean
cockroaches that were this size two feet
and
dinosaurs and every
every kind that we find is larger in the
fossil record whether we're talking
about
elephants whether we're talking about
wolves whether we're talking about
lions it doesn't matter everything was
larger
in the past yes so we have really
deteriorated
it's not a progressive evolution it's a
devolution
so there's no doubt that the people were
very large and the bible gives some
dimensions
even of the canaanite kings how large
their beds were for example
i mean these people were huge right yeah
they would probably not even fit into
this building without ducking their
heads
so yes they were giants but they were
also apostates
and these apostates were the ones that
eventually
led to the corruption of the entire race
so the sons of god are those that
followed
god the sons daughters of men and the
sons of men were those that didn't
they intermingled the rest is history
there came a flood
the other question is why was the book
of enoch
not put into the canon
well all the apocryphal books appeared
between three and four hundred years
after the close of the canon
both in the case of the new testament
and in the case of the old testament
okay so the canon was closed
basically so why would you add a book
and then there are there are certain
portions
in the book of enoch which do not
harmonize with the canon
and that is enough to the law and to the
testimony
if they speak not according to this word
there is no light in them
and mingling truth and error
is not something that is conducive
to good doctrine no so how are you going
to pick out what is truth and what is
not truth so if you find something in
the writings which is
obviously contrary to the law and to the
testimony you reject the whole book
okay thank you very much okay next
question
well two questions on chapter 10 and 13
of revelation
in revelation 10 verse 6
last part of the verse says that there
should be
time no longer is this referring to 1844
as the end of the 2300
prophetic days or should it be
correlated
with verse 7 and applied in time when
the seventh angel shall begin to sound
revelation chapter 10
is the opening of the scroll right
and this was a scroll that was sealed
and it lay open in the hands of the
angel right
and the prophet was told to come
and eat the scroll yeah in other words
he was to internalize it because
whenever you read in the old testament
that the scroll was to be eaten it meant
it was to be internalized it was to be
understood yeah
so the whole of revelation chapter 10
deals with the unsealing of
some portion of scripture that had
been sealed yes now there's only one
portion in the entire scripture that was
actually sealed
and that we find in the book of daniel
and it concerns the close of the 2
300 day prophecy
so if this angel had a
scroll that was unsealed at a particular
time
then it must refer to one because you
have to go to the law and the testimony
and you have to have harmony right yes
correct
so it can only mean time no longer
means no more prophetic time correct
because if it went meant literally no
more time we wouldn't be here anymore
right so to go and correlate it
with verses that follow
is a form of futurism you're taking
something
out of the historic context and applying
it to something
else without a biblical directive
so it stick to what the bible is it was
like
the last week of the 70 weeks
exactly take out and then apply it in
another place you can't do that because
there's there's no biblical directive
that tells you that you can do that yeah
yeah okay and the second part of this
question
the prophecies in the book of daniel are
in the vast majority already fulfilled
in the book of revelation chapter 13
presents to us the beast in the time
after the deadly wound is healed
could it be that the 42 months in verse
are literally three and a half years the
same
answer applies yes exactly the same
so most of the prophecies in the book of
daniel
are fulfilled
the detail has to still be
rounded off right so they are in a
historic continuous context
so now if you want to take those 42
months
which are in a historic continuous
context and you want to make them
literal then you are applying rules of
futurism
correct and you are negating the rules
of historic
continuous and with what right would you
do that
where's your directive that you can say
all right here it is prophetic time and
there it is literal time you are mixing
and jumbling
so stick to prophetic time thank you
please could you clarify the explanation
of why the ceremonial law was to be a
witness against us
because like you said it pointed to us
as sinners who needed redemption
does the moral law do that as well if it
does
then can we say that the moral law is a
witness against us too
this is a very good question the
ceremonial law was written by
moses and it was played beside the ark
as a witness against us yes
the law of ten commandments was written
with the finger of god
and placed within the ark of the
covenant
so they are two distinct laws yes
the one is pointing
to the moral directives and code
of god written by his finger he added
nothing
more and written in stone means it is
unchangeable so the law of god
stands now what does the law of god do
it tells us what is right and wrong it's
like a mirror
yes and when you look into that mirror
of the law
then you will find out that you are
falling far
short of the requirements have you never
coveted anything
uh no i probably have you probably have
all right okay so we could go through
the ten commandments i'm sure you
haven't covered anybody to death yet
right
in your mind
so we fall far short
of the directives of god
and the ten commandments condemn
us to death yes but they are
just a mirror they are just laws that
are written there
they cannot save us and even if i should
go back
and come back into harmony with this law
of god i'm already a transgressor
that's correct all right so the law of
god
transgression is defined by
the law of god what does the ceremonial
law do
it points to the solution yes the
ceremonial law points to solution
and the solution is a person
and that person is jesus christ
now what does the ceremonial law tell me
is going to happen with jesus christ
he's going to be crucified he's going to
be crucified
the lamb of god that takes away the sins
of the world
the innocent dying for the guilty
so the ceremonial law
tells me what the consequences were
now who was responsible for those
consequences
we was god responsible no no
am i responsible yes absolutely
i'm responsible so when i look at the
cross
does the cross the very fact that the
cross is there
does it show me that i
am the transgressor yes yes
the law of god doesn't die for me
the law of god just tells me i'm a law
breaker
yes and that is its function
it tells me what sin is and it tells me
that i am a law breaker it doesn't
provide a solution
and it doesn't kill anybody right
there must still be a judgment there
must still be someone who executes you
and that someone has decided to execute
himself
that is mind-boggling yeah
right amazing that's amazing
so here he has decided to take
my place now how should that make me
feel
guilty that can make me feel guilty
breaking the law in some people
is like having fun exactly
but seeing the consequences hanging on
that cross
shows me where the problem was it lies
and therefore it is against us
and is designed to
reach us and make us realize
where sin leads to and bring us
in repentance to the foot of the cross
and by the way it is god who draws
and it is god who enables us to repent
there is nothing that i can contribute
not even your yeah not even your
repentance
even my repentance is
his perfect repentance imputed
to me yeah it's beautiful
let me think of that beautiful hymn
amazing love how can it be
that now my god should die for me
exactly so this whole question
has really at at its heart the issue of
justification
justification is this amazing judicial
act of imputing to you
the righteousness of christ which is
alien to you it is foreign to you
and the natural man
with his sinful nature rebels against
them
so even the change of heart that takes
place
after which which is called
sanctification
is a work that god has to do and in
order to be able to do that
that cross must be constantly before
your mind
and before your mind's eye because
this is the consequence and your
natural nature will fight against
righteousness
and you have to clobber it to death
every single
every single day probably more than once
[Laughter]
thank you please would you talk about
the second great exodus
at the end times in scripture the bible
tells us that
it will be so great and so awesome
that no one will ever speak of the first
one anymore
please would you speak on the second
great exodus and how close do you think
we are to it
all right there are two ways of looking
at this
an exodus the typical exodus started
with people leaving egypt and
going towards canaan and then there was
the entrance into canaan which typifies
another event
which is the entrance into the
anti-typical canaan
so where do we want to start with the
exodus so let's start with the exodus
of coming out of egypt
there's a call in revelation chapter 18
that you have to come out of
babylon of course that implies that you
must come out of egypt as well
yes now if you were
an egyptian like myself then you were an
atheist
and if you were a babylonian like i also
was
then i also have to come out of babylon
i have to come out of them what is
babylon babylon is religious confusion
and where can i become unconfused as to
the bible
and that is in the word of god right
correct so i have to accept
every precept in the word of god
and come into harmony with god's law
then i will have an exodus out of
babylon and
if i leave my secular thinking behind i
have an
exit exodus out of egypt yes
so when does this great exodus start
well there again are you talking
corporately or individually
individually it starts when you make the
decision that you're going to follow
christ in all his ways
then you come out of egypt or babylon or
both
yes because we all have a bit of egypt
and we all have a bit of babylon
and we have to come out of it so there's
an
individual choice corporately when was
there a call to come out of babylon that
was
in 1844 in 1844
the second angel's message was
proclaimed which means babylon
is fallen and if babylon is fallen
that implies that you have to come
out of her so out of all the
denominations people came together
and joined together and eventually
formed a group that keeps the
commandments of
god and holds to the testimony of jesus
and it started in the millerite movement
so that's
the corporate exodus that took place and
you can join up with that movement
just like the egyptians joined up with
the israelites
to go together and some yeah
so there's a corporate one there's an
individual one
and if we are referring to going into
canaan
that will take place at the second
coming of christ yes
and the part of the question that says
how close do you think we are to it
let's just say very close thank you
okay next question i went to a church
where the man preaching quoted
revelation 22 where jesus said
i am the bright and morning star and
then proceeded to tell the congregation
that lucifer means
morning star so jesus will take the name
lucifer at the end of time
any help please lucifer was the name
of the covering cherub
and he was a bright
star yeah and but who
is the ultimate bright morning star
jesus
jesus christ now what does lucifer want
to do
take over he wants to be like god right
he wants to be
like god so he wants to usurp
his position and take a position that is
not
rightfully his so yes he was
lucifer but he fell and he became
satan but jesus
has a name and that name
means yahweh saves
yesus jesus means yavi
saves he is the savior and that is his
name
he has another name that is written on
his thigh
that nobody can know until it has been
revealed
so there is no evidence at all in the
scripture
that he will call himself lucifer no
okay
thank you there are those that teach
that jesus and satan are brothers
coexisting from before the creation they
say that jesus is the son of light and
satan is the son of darkness
and that this must be so because the
bible teaches that god creates evil and
good
why does the sda church teach about this
this is an amazing statement or question
now the occult world teaches this okay
the occult world teaches in fact that
lucifer was the older brother
and that jesus was the younger brother
and they teach that the older brother is
going to
regain his original seat
and that just like he obtained the
victory at the cross
so he will obtain the victory at the end
as well
so that's what the occult will teach us
but we have some news for them
that is not the case that denies of
course the atonement yes
entirely and the bible is
full of the atonement moreover
satan has tried to get rid of the bible
over and over and over again
has he succeeded no has he managed to
succeed in making the scriptures hard to
find
yes yes he's managed that has he
eradicated them the true scriptures
nope no everybody can still get hold of
them
so you can't get rid of them no so who's
the stronger
definitely jesus jesus all right has he
tried to
eradicate christianity yes has he
eradicated true
christianity entirely no no so who's the
stronger
definitely the more he tries the more he
loses right
okay he might have more souls on his
side
but they are basically walking dead
whereas if you are in christ you are a
new person
and you have entered into life even when
you are when you're dead
christ doesn't call you dead he calls
you asleep yeah
lazarus is sleeping sleeping
so this is an occult teaching and it is
as far removed from the bible
as the east is from the west the only
one
who is immortal is god
correct and jesus christ was god
in the fullest sins there was never a
time when he was not
even though people would like to make
him a created being
he is from eternity
in him was life unborrowed and derived
we have discussed this
many many times so
he created all things
that means he created the angels correct
and
lucifer was an angel and the bible
clearly states
you were perfect from the day you were
what is the operative word great created
he's a created being
now i thought about this quite a lot
if you were created an adult
would you be able to remember the time
when you were not
no no but you were born right
correct can you remember the time now
when you were not
no but you can conclude that there must
have been a time when you were not
because you know that babies are born
yes and that before they were born
or conceived they were not they were not
yes
so by simple observation you know that
you were not
yes but if you were suddenly there as an
adult would you remember a time when you
were not
no no so lucifer
looks at jesus christ and god
being the unselfish being that he
is created him as near as possible to
himself
right correct without the
inherent eternal life eternal life
was always subject to obedience
and the same thing happened in the
garden of eden
god created adam and eve and again he
put the tree of
knowledge of good and evil there and
told them quite plainly
that the day they transgress they would
forfeit
eternal life yes the wages of sin
is death the day you eat of it you will
surely
die now satan refuses to believe that
because he sees himself like the son of
god
the highest of the angels and he's
asking himself
why is christ being incorporated
in the discussions of the godhood and he
excluded
from that communication and so
jealousy arose in his heart and he
wanted to be
like the most high yes and he's still
playing that role today
and he is playing that role out
through his representative who also says
that he is a god on this earth yes
and then the part of that god creates
evil
he doesn't create evil it's a choice
it's a choice but if you
have freedom of choice absolute freedom
of choice
is there a possibility that you could
go against god's will yes and if you go
against
god's will that is called evil yes
right now god as the author
of righteousness has defined clearly
what the rules of righteousness are
and the devil and his
associates decided to go against that
so you were perfect
from the day that you were created until
iniquity was found where
in you in you
so why was iniquity found
in him because god created the iniquity
no because god created the possibility
by giving him freedom of choice exactly
but when he exercised that choice
that is when iniquity was found in him
so god never wanted anyone to have the
knowledge of evil
he only wanted to have them to have the
knowledge of good
now eastern mysticism says that the one
cannot exist without the other
yes so they therefore you have this yin
yang
principle so you have good and evil and
the fact that there is evil tells you
that there is good and the fact that
there is good
tells you that there is evil and they
are in perfect balance with each other
and
even in the occult world you have what
we call
a luciferian and then you have a
satanist
okay the one practices
the opposite of the of the two poles
and the one is white and the other one
is black yeah so you've got the black
magic and white matter and the young
yang is also white and black
right yeah so it's the same thing
now is that a reality do you
really have to have evil in order to
know what is good
no or could you just have good without
the evil
but what's heaven going to be like yes
without any evil there will be no evil
there will be no iniquity in it it will
have been
eradicated why because people
chose not to do it those that are there
those that will be there for all
eternity
have made a conscious decision to reject
evil and have
come into harmony with god and permitted
god to change them
back to his original design
concept correct so evil is a choice
and yin yang is a figment of the
imagination
that condones evil in
the supposed realm of
elevating the good you can you can take
that into the theological role
the realm where you have predestination
and some of the theologians in that line
of thinking
say that god created everything and
therefore he also created evil
and he created the heaven and he created
the hell
and god either predestines you to go to
heaven or to go to hell
now in that theology some people went so
far
as to say that you need the hell
in order to elevate the glory of the
heaven
by the contrast now that's yin yang
thinking
and that's not biblical that makes god
the author of evil
and makes him a tyrant yeah that's
almost like
if you say there's an eternal hell yes
it has to
they say that it has to be there so that
it can elevate
yes now i always say
and uh so did wesley say and many others
that that would make god worse than the
devil yeah
because what joy can they be in heaven
if for example you see your loved ones
suffering
eternal torment there can be no joy in
heaven there will be a
perpetual tears right so
the only way in which this can be dealt
with is in the biblical way god says he
will eradicate evil it shall be no
more it shall not raise its head a
second time
and the wicked will be like
dust they will be ashes under your feet
they will be consumed they will be like
smoke they will be gone so this whole
doctrine of
yin yang has permeated even the
religious
realm and there's no biblical basis for
it
thank you several times you have talked
about global changes and the science
behind it
how does the following statement work in
conjunction with the scientific theory
although the lord has ceased his working
in creating
he is constantly employed in upholding
and using his servants the things which
he has made
said jesus my father worketh either to
and i work the material world is under
god's control
the laws that govern all nature are
obeyed by nature
everything speaks and acts the will of
the creator
deity is the author of nature the
natural world has
in itself no power but that which god
supplies i think what the person is
asking is why if god sustains
everything
is there a deterioration and a change
globally
why doesn't god retain it in its perfect
state well god also says
in his bible that the earth will wear
out like a garment
yes so when he originally created it
it was vibrant and perfect and there
were no
genetic defects but when sin came
into the world and the tree of life was
removed which
retained everything in perfect order
not that the tree was necessary god
could have done it
without the tree but the tree was to
serve as a reminder to everyone that
we are dependent upon god
otherwise you know you forget
and you carry on with your own life so
the bible tells us that from the moment
that sin entered into the world
things changed the animals changed death
came
into the world there must be a
deterioration
but god permitted a certain portion of
time
to elapse before that would take place
so before the flood it was
a very long time and adam
was over 900 years old that was the age
that they
reached at that time after the flood
there was a deterioration
and it dropped to 400 then into the 200
and then eventually down to 17
over the ages so god permitted that
deterioration
he also permitted the deterioration of
the earth
in fact it says that the ground is
cursed
yes which means it will not yield to you
what it yielded before
before it yielded in abundance
and easily now by the sweat of your brow
it will yield to you and you will have
to contend
with weeds and alien plants etc
thorns so yes god
maintains your life within the
boundaries
that he has set and he maintains the
earth and the life on it
within the boundaries that he has set
and it will deteriorate and continue to
deteriorate
until you get to a point where it will
not uphold any life but prior to that he
will come
because he says else no flesh would
survive yes
correct yes beautiful here are five
questions is it right to call pope
francis the man of sin
well let's put it this way the bible
talks about the antichrist and it says
there were many antichrists that have
gone into the world
and it gives a very long time frame for
the existence of the little horn power
so we are dealing not with the man we
are dealing
with the system it is an antichrist
system so we do not
attack the man but we can
expose what the man says yes
and we can expose whether the man
is speaking in harmony with the system
which is the antichrist's system yes
so i would not call pope francis the
antichrist
but i would call the system that he
propagates the antichrist system
and he is the spokesperson for this is
that system
yeah and his position puts him in that
man of sin position it's not to say that
he's not the man of sin his
organization that has the directives
which are contrary to the word of god
is the antichrist system yes okay second
question
is it right to say that anyone who has
been a pope will not go to heaven
well the bible says that is not for us
to judge
that is for god to judge great who knows
whether there
is a pope who has repented of his ways
or of his actions
while in that official capacity
so that is not for me to judge will
leave that
to god correct but if you stand
by those principles and you
accept the arrogance of the position
that you hold then you are obviously
acting contrary to god's law
and god's will which in the first
commandment says thou shalt have no
other gods beside me and these people
say that they are god
on earth well that is a serious issue
that is doing exactly what lucifer did
and lucifer won't be in heaven
correct but let's leave the individual
choice to god
is it right to expose the sins happening
in the church
we are supposed to expose
wickedness and the
the word of god empowers god's people
to speak against wickedness in the
church and you can just take the
examples in the bible
did god's people did the disciples
expose wickedness
even within their own ranks did paul
rebuke
false ideas
and ideologies within the church these
letters
absolutely so yes you may expose the
sins
do not attack the man no but
expose the error yes i do not believe
in turning my weapons against the church
militant but i do believe
that it is right to state when something
is wrong
and leave it there without going so far
as to attack the man as i always
use the example of caiaphas
and aaron i i would judge
differently to what god judges right
yeah
and i would think that aaron was
apostate by making a golden cough and
lying about it i mean i've used this
example many times
and i'd be dead wrong yes and caiaphas
was the tithe-paying sabbath-keeping
perfect example of what a leader should
be like and he crucified christ
so i will not talk about the man
sometimes it's hard not to know who the
man is
especially if they publish something and
they put something into a public realm
then sometimes a public issue needs a
public response
but in general i do not believe it is
right to turn
our weapons against the church and it's
also every person's duty
when truth is presented to and they
realize that there's
someone inside of the church that's not
adhering to this
not to follow those persons exactly and
also
there's a way in dealing with with these
issues
you can be exceedingly authoritarian
forgetting that you yourself are
in need of redemption so the bible tells
us that we
should in all kindness rebuke people
or take them aside and say
talk to them about what the issue is
following the biblical directives and if
they don't listen then take it to the
church
and sometimes these things get very
complicated
but as far as is possible let the law of
kindness be upon your lips
and i would also just maybe reiterate
that
when an institution or a person
is apostate it doesn't make the body
of the church of our state no no
that has to be decided by a church
council
which is called like the first council
in jerusalem
in other words a general conference
decision
and if that is apostate then you have a
problem
but if individuals do whatever they
they deem fit to do then
you can expose the error
and leave the consequences to god
i mean and then did god ever rebuke the
political government or
did he just rebuke the church well the
bible is
full of rebuke for political systems
i mean if you read the prophets there
are
lists upon lists upon lists about what
will happen to babylon what will happen
to edom what will happen to this one and
that one
so governments have certainly been
rebuked
and the bible is very clear that in
future
all political systems will come to an
end yeah
all of them and the kings of the world
will give their power unto the beast
and the beast was taken and with him the
false prophet
and later on the kings and their armies
were destroyed
by christ himself by the
breath of his mouth so yes there
are very strong directives against
political systems in the world
the four beasts of daniel absolutely
and even the ten horns i mean they
are in cahoots with uh
with the system that is usurping its
authority and
and pretending to be a god on this earth
so yes god has rebuked political
governments
and he is giving a serious warning
for the governments of the last days
and individuals will turn from the
ideologies that are being propagated
because
it will be so clear
that legislations that are coming out in
the world will be
so blatantly contrary to god's will and
god's law
that even a child should be able to see
that to be in harmony with it is to be
in enmity with god yes yes and then the
final question
what is the church's stance with regard
to politics
well politics has to do with the
kingdoms of this world
if you have become an ambassador for
christ
then you should not be
involved in politics because
just like an ambassador from another
country
has no voting rights in the country
where he is representing his country
so an ambassador for the kingdom of god
should also not choose sides when it
comes to these
issues because these these arguments
concern the kingdoms of this world
and uh we should stand aloof of it yes
thank you
will you close for us with the word of
prayer yes certainly
heavenly father people have many
questions
and answers can only be supplied from
the word of god
and i pray that that which we have
discussed
will be in harmony with with what you
have told us in your word
and may people study your word and find
out
for themselves too what is the will of
god
in the time that we are living in the
world is rapidly
coming to a close the signs of
fulfilling all around us
and we all have to make decisions for or
against the greatest choice that we can
make is to come to the foot of the cross
and to kneel at the foot of the cross
and accept
this great gift of salvation help
each and every one of us to cling to the
cross
to cringe to christ and to
cherish that justification which can
only come from him
it's my prayer in jesus name amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you